HEATH ROWE: Good afternoon.
My name is Heath Rowe.
And we're happy to be
here this afternoon
for Authors at Google.
We have a guest today by the
name of Tom Folsom, who's
written a recent biography about
Dennis Hopper called,
appropriately enough, "Hopper,
A Journey into the American
Dream." It's an "LA Times"
best seller.
And given that Hopper has such
a rich history in Venice and
in Los Angeles, not just through
his movie making but
through his art collecting and
his life, we thought it
totally appropriate
to bring in Tom.
Hopper's house was just 0.3
miles away, on Indiana Avenue.
And so if you haven't walked
past that three house number
compound, it's worth
taking a look at.
And his first movie, "Rebel
Without a Cause," shot with
James Dean, was almost entirely
in Los Angeles, some
in Los Feliz, other
parts, including
Santa Monica High School.
And so we're proud to have Tom
Folsom here today, to talk to
us about Hopper and his book.
Mr. Folsom.
TOM FOLSOM: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM FOLSOM: Great to be here.
So Hopper and LA, let's
get down to it.
Hopper moved to Los Angeles
when he was 18 years old.
He was born and raised in, of
all places, Dodge City,
Kansas, where they would have
Wyatt Earp and his sidekick
Doc Holliday would shoot
it up in the Wild West.
So this sort of sets the tone
for what I felt was Hopper's
just improbably iconic life.
I mean the thing about this
guy is, which you don't
realize, he pops
up everywhere.
It's sort of like--
I don't know-- as one person
put it, like a
stoned Forrest Gump.
But you'll see him in the
LA pop art scene.
He's buying one of the first
Andy Warhol Soup Cans.
You'll see him with James Dean
in "Rebel Without a Cause."
You follow this guy's trail, and
it's sort of extraordinary
where this journey took him.
So I'm going to be talking about
the journey in a second.
But let's get back to Hopper
at 18 years old.
Now, he's moved from Dodge
City, Kansas, to, of all
places, San Diego, sort of like
that "Go West, young man"
sort of migration after
World War II.
So he ends up in San Diego.
At 13, he makes his professional
debut at San
Diego's Old Globe Theatre.
It's a replica of the
Shakespearean theater.
So by the time he's 18, he's
actually a classically trained
Shakespearean actor.
He's won the National
Shakespeare Competition.
Right after he graduated high
school, he was voted most
likely to succeed.
I mean, when we look at Dennis,
we sort of have
different variations of this,
when we look back on him.
Either that or sort of the
shaggy, pot smoking "Easy
Rider" guy.
But in high school, he was
just totally clean-cut.
From what I've heard from people
that went to school
with him, he wasn't really
that wild, either.
All he was doing was acting.
He knew what he wanted, and
that was to be an actor.
So by the time, again, he's 18
years old, he's just landed
this role in this film, "Rebel
Without a Cause." It's his
very first film, because he's
been signed by Warner
Brothers, after doing sort of
this terrific television tour
de force in a show called
"Medic." It was a very real
hospital drama.
And so Dennis played sort
of a young patient.
And he's got those
haunting eyes.
And so people loved him.
So he had all these studio
offers immediately after.
But his idea of acting was
Shakespearean, which was
really funny.
I mean that eloquent diction.
I mean his heroes were
really Orson Welles
and Laurence Olivier.
So you can imagine just this
sort of strange looking,
eerily handsome, young man
who's doing Shakespeare.
This is the style
of great acting.
So, well, what happens?
He's on the set of "Rebel
Without a Cause," filmed
around Los Angeles.
Up at the observatory,
he sees James Dean.
And James Dean is doing these
things with acting that is
totally off the map.
It's a little bit in the
tradition of Marlon Brando
and, before him, Montgomery
Clift.
But it's very much every
take is different that
James Dean's doing.
He's sort of almost
like animal in
the way that he moves.
And he's got this thing.
He wants it to be real.
And so when they're doing this
switchblade scene in "Rebel
Without a Cause," up at the
observatory, it's James Dean,
if you remember, and he's
against the bully gang leader,
this guy, Buzz.
So these guys are like
mano-a-mano.
But like Dean wants to use
real switchblades.
He wants that realism.
And so, in the course of playing
around with real
switchblades, James Dean gets
cut behind the ear.
And so Nicholas Ray, the
director, he yells cut.
And Dean just freaks out.
He's like, if I'm in
the moment, don't
ever tell me to cut.
As Hopper put it, he almost
threatened to murder his
director with the switchblade.
But that's the sort of
commitment that Dean had to
being real.
And it totally changed
Hopper's way of
thinking about acting.
I mean, by all indications, he
was really like the good boy
who wanted to please.
He wanted to do the right thing,
act the right way.
But Dean, he's doing something
completely-- he's arguing with
the director.
He's pulling a knife
on the guy.
So you have to think.
When you're 18 years old, you're
that impressionable.
I mean, this is your
first movie.
And then considering what
James Dean became.
I mean, at the point of "Rebel
Without a Cause," James Dean
was definitely like the
next big thing.
But he'd only been in
"East of Eden." He'd
only been in one film.
And so Hopper acts with him in
"Rebel Without a Cause." and
then his next film is "Giant,"
also with James Dean, and
filmed down in Marfa, Texas.
So you can imagine, back to back
films with James Dean.
Right after when he finished
"Giant" in the summer of 1955,
James Dean is spectacularly
killed, in his Porsche Silver
Spyder, going off to a race.
So by the time "Rebel Without
a Cause" comes out, I mean,
it's a dead man on the screen.
But audiences just couldn't
believe that
he was really dead.
He was like the number
one movie star.
He was beating out
Rock Hudson.
And we was getting tons of fan
mail, just like no one wanted
to believe that this amazingly
vibrant actor was dead.
I mean, how could he be dead?
So Hopper, of all people, he's
about three or four years
younger than Dean, he's sort of
looked to, by the studios,
as the next James Dean.
So that's pretty big
shoes to fill.
Just because Hopper
had an intensity.
He had worked with Dean
for two films.
He was the natural
heir apparent.
Well, he definitely got swept
up in that, I think, so much
to the point that he starts to
argue with directors, himself.
And he makes himself sort
of known as being
difficult to work with.
All of this in this sort of
attempt to live up to James
Dean's legacy.
It gets to the point where, as
Hopper tells it, it's the
second year of his studio
contract, it's 1957, he has
this spectacular showdown with
his director, Henry Hathaway,
on the set of this B-Western
called "From Hell to Texas."
And, as Hopper puts it, 86
times, the director's telling
him, no, I want you
to do it this way.
And Hopper's like, no, I'm
not going to do it.
I'm going to do it this way.
And it just keeps going in this
epic showdown that Hopper
inevitably loses.
Because he's not quite James
Dean, in terms of his star
power, how people project him.
So anyway, Hopper's pretty
much, as he puts it, he's
blackballed from Hollywood.
But he's still young.
He's only like 20,
21 years old.
So what are you going to do?
Well, he goes to the
Actors Studio.
He follows sort of James Dean's
footsteps, wants to
teach at the Actors Studio.
And then he sort of picks up
some work around Hollywood
doing a lot of television
and doing smaller films.
One of which is this film filmed
right here in Venice.
It's called "Night Tide."
Looking back, Hopper says it
was the first, real,
independent film.
But then, it was just like a
couple of really strange
people, with cameras, filming
this really weird guy.
Hopper plays sailor.
And he falls in love with
a sideshow mermaid.
And it's a very cult-y,
underground film.
But it's extremely cool.
I really recommend, if you
haven't gotten a chance to see
it, go check it out.
And you'll definitely get
a sense of weird Venice.
It's all filled with carnies
and fringe characters.
It's a lot of fun.
That's the film "Night Tide."
What else is he doing?
Well, he's got some
time on his hands.
I mean, Hopper was a
compulsive creator.
He really wanted to work.
He comes from good Dodge
City, Kansas, stock.
So he gets involved
in the arts scene
that's percolating around.
It's a counterpoint to what
they're doing in the East.
And Hopper would hang around
with these abstract
expressionists at the Cedar
Tavern, when he was out at the
Actors Studio, in New York.
But there was something else
going on in LA, too.
And it's all about guys who want
to use the LA aesthetic,
the aesthetic of the road,
of sleek new--
car culture.
These guys are incorporating
that into their art.
And it becomes a counterbalance
to what's
happening in New York.
Now Hopper is extremely
active in this.
He knows all of the players.
He's actually making
art himself.
He's taking a lot of
photos, as well.
He's got some really terrific
photos of the pop
art scene in LA.
Now people weren't even calling
it pop art then,
because it didn't even
have a name.
And one day, Dennis Hopper, he's
hanging out at the Ferus
Gallery, on La Cienega, and
he sees this comic strip.
And why is there a comic
strip on a wall?
It's liked framed as art.
Well, of course, it's
a Lichtenstein.
But Hopper, he loses it.
He goes nuts.
He's like, wow, that's it.
This is our reality.
This is not, for Hopper, that
sort of brooding, abstract
expressionism that he'd been
introduced to in the East.
That brooding thing also was
very much tied to the Actors
Studio and that style
of acting.
And people see a lot of
parallels between Jackson
Pollock and Brando as well.
I mean even just that tough,
macho thing, but just sort of
like creating strange
things from within.
But all of a sudden, Hopper sees
this, and it's like pop.
And Hopper's been doing, at this
time, looking back, like
cheesy TV but also groovy.
He's playing the reincarnated
Nazi in "The Twilight Zone."
He's playing in Bobbie Jo and
the beatnik episode on
"Beverly Hillbillies."
He plays this
strange, beatnik guy.
But Hopper is sort
of a pop savant.
That was one thing
that he got.
And in getting that, he bought
one of the first
Andy Warhol Soup Cans.
So where does this
eye come from?
I mean he was not a classically
trained.
I mean, he was from Dodge
City, of all places.
And he grew up on a dirt farm.
But looking back, people just
said, Hopper just got it, like
he really got pop.
And at this point, James Dean
was also that great pop icon
after his death.
So I think that has a lot to
do with Hopper's experience
under James Dean.
I mean, for me, all things,
with Hopper's
journey, come from Dean.
Where is this going
to take you?
Well, it takes Hopper to--
he wants to be where
the action is.
He wants to see what's
happening.
I think it's that awesome
documentary quality that you
find in "Easy Rider."
A lot of that movie was
just him and his
location scout guy.
And they were riding around,
looking for locations, and
they put what they saw
into the movie.
So that's sort of the thing, for
me, that really stands out
about Hopper, as a great
filmmaker, is just that
quality of wanting to be there
where it's happening.
Well, this is sort of brings
Hopper everywhere.
It takes him to Haight-Ashbury
in the '60s.
It takes him to like Taos, New
Mexico, in the '70s, after he
does "Easy Rider," which
was, of course,
a phenomenal success.
And he gets involved
in this whole--
which is on the cover, here--
cosmic cowboy scene.
This is the same thing, when
you think about like great
Kris Kristofferson songs, one
of which he actually wrote
about Dennis.
And those two had a connection
as well.
Dennis offering Kris
Kristofferson his first acting
gig in a film called "The Last
Movie," that was shot in Peru.
So it keeps taking
him to where it's
happening in pop culture.
But always wanting to be where
the action is also taking its
toll on Hopper.
I mean, one of the things
that he followed
was the drug scene.
And he would ingest copious
amounts of whatever the
happening drug was
at the time.
The '70s being tons
of cocaine.
Well, this sort of proves
unsustainable.
And I feel that like, at the end
of every chapter, how did
Hopper live through
this chapter?
But somehow he did it.
And lo and behold, when people
thought, you know what,
Dennis, he's a goner.
He was so far gone, you would
find him wandering around
Mexico, in the jungle, naked.
What is up with this guy?
You know what, he gets sober.
He gets to the point where
he can't do it anymore.
He does the 12 steps.
He gets sober.
And, of all places, he leaves
Taos, New Mexico, and he moves
to Venice, Venice in the mid
'80s being a very different
scene from Venice today.
So I'm going to read a chapter
about Hopper coming to Venice
and one of the more improbable
movies that you're like, wow,
Dennis Hopper did that?
It's a movie called "Colors",
about the LA gang scene.
So I'm going to read
this chapter.
It's called "Colors."
In a tweed suit, Hopper moseyed
through the land of
the unwanted, abandoned autos,
burned-down homes,
trash-littered sidewalks.
He was accompanied by his
female, bodybuilder friend,
from Beverly Hills, who'd
recently appeared in Playboy
and was a muse for fine art
photographer Robert
Mapplethorpe.
Hopper climbed over a
graffiti-littered wall at the
end of a dead-end alley.
Three, silver, futuristic
bunkers loomed in the
wasteland of Venice
Beach, California.
I love them, said Hopper.
I just love them.
These are so amazing,
ingenious.
The trio of shacks seemed to
have been built for Hopper.
He felt as if he'd commissioned
them, much to the
delight of Venice artists Laddie
John Dill and Chuck
Arnoldi, up a creek financially
on their artist
colony sinkhole in the ghetto
that they'd gotten budding
architect Frank Gehry
to design.
Only the buildings were built
backwards, because the
blueprints were read that way.
One would-be tenant, a UCLA
student, squinted at the
graffiti and deciphered a
death threat and split.
And the only takers, so far,
were the cops, who'd been
using these bunkers for
surveillance to bust a crack
house across the street.
Well, Hopper snapped one up in
1987, with plans to get the
other shacks when he could.
So in gangsta style, he rolled
around his 'hood in a two-tone
brown Cadillac Seville with gold
wire rims, surveying the
turf for his new movie,
"Colors," staring bad-boy
actor Sean Penn.
"We're here to learn about
gangs," announced Sean, at a
meeting of CRASH, Community
Resources Against Street
Hoodlums, which was
an LAPD gang unit.
"Yeah, well good fucking
luck, pal," said
Detective Dennis Fanning.
Detective Fanning was recruited
as the technical
advisor on "Colors." And for
three months, the LAPD stuck
Sean Penn in the backseat
of a squad car.
Sometimes, when you're with
someone, says Fanning, you
know, a partner, they could be
the greatest cop in the world.
And you could be the greatest
cop in the world.
But you two don't
have karma, when
you're in a car, together--
Fanning's explaining this to
me at an Orange County,
Starbucks--
you know, the thing
is, is just you're
always 10 minutes late.
You know, the bad guy
just left, or the
shooting just went down.
But there's other times, you get
in a car with somebody and
boom, it's right there.
The karma's there.
You turn the corner.
There's the guy with the gun.
You walk into the store.
It's getting robbed.
You pull up to the light.
There's a stolen car.
That's pretty much how
it was with Seany.
Sean, he'd get in the car, and
he'd turned it into a shit
magnet, which is nice, because
guys who consider themselves
good street cops like to be
considered ship magnets.
And, as a great shit magnet,
Sean wanted nobody else to
direct "Colors" but Dennis
Hopper, seeing as he and his
wife, Madonna--
Mo in cop talk--
were big fans of "Out of the
Blue," Hopper's sort of
forgotten, strange '80s punk
movie, shot in Vancouver.
Now "Colors" was originally
scripted to be about cough
syrup abuse.
But Hopper drastically recast it
to explore the volatile LA
gang scene, with Crips and
Bloods killing each other on
the streets of South Central,
like cowboys and Indians.
His subject was considered so
outlandish at the time, that
some critics actually thought
he made it up.
But living in Venice Beach,
homeboy Dennis got to know the
local gang kids on
a personal level.
And he thought it was just a
waste of really meaningful
talent, thoughtfulness,
and energy.
Well, Dennis told me his crazy
stories of when he left the
hospital and of walking down the
road in his fucking PJs,
recounted Detective Fanning,
of some of the war stories
that he and Hopper would tell.
And Hopper would tell him
about his rehab and his
wanderings in the
Mexican jungle.
Well, says, Fanning, me and him,
we had the same stories,
just different sides
of the fence.
We got along famously.
I got like 10 or 15 cops into
the movie, because Dennis, he
wanted the realism.
But they also used real
gangsters, which made for real
fun breaking for lunch time on
the set, real cops on one
side, real gangsters
on the other.
It's heavy, man, says
rapper Ice-T--
of course--
you got to think, OK, Dennis,
he's in "Easy Rider,"
rocked-out white guy, getting
high, riding motorcycles.
You say, OK, he's on some
rebel white shit.
But then he's doing
a movie only
about blacks and Mexicans?
Well, Hopper wanted Ice-T's
"Yo, Homeboy, Squeeze the
Trigger" on the soundtrack.
So T went to a screening.
OK, says T, the movie's good.
And it had a kind of a fictional
line, because the
Mexicans and the blacks didn't
fight at the time.
But overall, I was kind
of like pro it.
But Rick James, he had
the title song.
You know, look good, all these
colors, or some shit.
And this is Ice-T giving me
his funkiest Rick James
impression.
But without asking, says T, I
left the studio, and we laid
the song, "Colors." I just
submitted it cold.
Then all of a sudden, this
ripple effect happens.
And everybody was like,
yo, Dennis Hopper
wants to meet you.
Yo, brother, this song
is the shit.
It's what the movie is.
It's all that.
Yo, this is the essence.
This is what it is.
This is like beyond
what I meant.
But this is, of course, homeboy
Dennis talking.
And Ice-T is listening
to this guy.
He suddenly thought he was in
"Apocalypse Now." He'd always
been a fan of Hopper's
rap in the movie.
It's like he's talking about
Kurtz, you know, says T, the
way he just takes the words and
jumbles them, and he spins
them, and he drops them.
And as a fellow artist, Ice-T
appreciated how Hopper always
really felt whatever
he was doing.
No stranger to controversy,
himself, Ice-T thought it was
unfortunate when the media
lashed out at Hopper's
finished vision, with the
media calling "Colors" a
disgrace and accusing him of
fabricating a gang situation.
Orion Pictures was afraid that
if they distributed "Colors"
in wide release that blood was
going to run in the streets.
So the studio offered to pay
for some security guards in
all of the release
theaters, with
protection outside and inside.
But still a lot of
theaters were too
nervous to open the movie.
When "Colors" opened in LA, in
'88, cops arrested nearly 150
gang members.
And a gang member was shot
to death outside of
a theater in Stockton.
But "Colors" was hot.
But unfortunately for the
producers, nobody really got
killed in the second week.
And there was no real
controversy.
So everything died, and
"Colors" was buried.
But if only the suits, man,
if they'd only put in wide
release more aggressively that
first week, they could've made
a fortune off of Hopper.
So where does this
leave Hopper?
Well, he's left with pack of red
bereted Guardian Angels,
who were outside his compound,
protesting his depiction of
inner city youth.
Clearly, Hopper needs to
fortify at this point.
So he buys the Gehry shack on
the vacant lot behind him.
And he proceeds with phase
two of his compound.
Up goes a silver, futuristic,
fortress skin, with a
wave-like, hyperbolic roof and
an asymmetrical, windowless,
industrial, corrugated
steel facade.
Hopper connected his original
Gehry shack to the second he
procured, with a series of
jarring, heavy-duty catwalks.
He bought a third bunker
a few years later.
It was like a paranoid cocaine
drug lord's insane bunker,
only sober, in Hopper's case.
But they had video monitors
playing for him, like an
ongoing surveillance loop,
which fed into Hopper's
paranoia and served as also
artful background footage.
And all the lights in his
house would flash at any
unauthorized footstep.
The compound was buttressed by
a handgun stuffed into one of
Hopper's socks and
a backup shotgun,
tucked away on the premises.
Completing his American dream
home, Hopper put up a white
picket fence, just like the kind
that Auntie Em put up in
the "Wizard of Oz" or something
you'd see along the
streets of "Blue Velvet's"
Lumberton, separating him from
Venice's mean streets.
There's a little door on one
side of the fence, in the
back, with razor wire all around
it, explained Hopper,
of one of the compound's
secret features.
After I put it up, I went out.
And I came back.
And the guys had sort of just
taken the door off, and they'd
laid it down.
It was still locked but
just laid down.
Well, I'm living on their
turf, you know.
I mean, it's my turf, too,
because this is America.
That's my reading
from "Colors".
And again, where do
we find Hopper?
We find him wanting to be
where the action is.
And he does this gang movie.
And before, he wanted to be
where the action was in the
1980s, with this film, "Out of
the Blue." And it was about
punk music.
It was really one of the first
movies about punk.
He's not really into punk.
He didn't really like punk.
But he liked reality.
He wanted to be where
it was happening.
So he covers the punk scene.
And he does this film "Colors",
like three years
before films like "Boyz in the
Hood" and that whole slew of
gang movies that came out.
The guy had a ton of faults,
but the one thing you could
say about him was that, a,
he had this extraordinary
journey, which is why I
really wanted to write
this book about him.
I mean, I really felt that this
was like a modern day Don
Quixote out chasing his
American dream.
But he did, he had an eye.
I mean he knew what was
significant and like what was
sort of garbage and crap.
He definitely did a lot of
crap in his later years.
But the guy wanted to work.
He was happy working.
The end of his life, I just
felt, he was like living,
breathing pop.
He'd be like in a Super
Bowl commercial, doing
those weird Nike ads.
And then you'd see him
in "Waterworld,"
with this eye patch.
And then you'd see him
in "Speed" as this
crazy, manic guy.
Someone told me later-- they
actually said that Hopper felt
that "Speed" was actually his
toughest acting role, because
he was basically locked
in a room on a phone.
And I mean, that's your range.
I mean he's just like, look.
But you know what, he really did
bring some amazing talent
to these roles.
But unlike a lot of actors,
whose lives are pretty much
just defined by the roles that
they do, and then, what do you
do in your downtime?
Well, I don't know.
I just hang around
and do lunches,
this, that, the other.
I mean I really felt the
Hopper's life, what came
between those roles, was really
greater than any of the
roles he'd ever played.
I think his greatest role
really was his own.
So thank you for listening
to me.
If you guys have any questions
or anything like that, I would
like to see where it goes.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM FOLSOM: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Were you concerned at
all, did you hear anything
about this, having a really
miserable marriage in the last
years of his life
hit him hard?
TOM FOLSOM: Even when he got
sober, I mean he was still the
same person.
This was a guy who, I felt,
wanted to literally live that
two-dimensional life
on the screen.
He wanted to be that cowboy
riding off into the sunset.
So the guy lived his
life like a movie.
And so when you do that, you're
going to have all these
tumultuous ups and downs.
But it's also tremendously
exciting.
I mean that's what
got him off.
It was really just wanting
to be always
where it was happening.
I never got the sense he
was really miserable.
He had those moments where
it was like a lot of--
at one point, he tells Charlie
Rose that he really considered
his whole career a failure.
But then there's also that side
where, maybe, he's just
playing the acting role of the
great, failed genius, like an
Orson Welles.
There's something really
romantic about that.
But who knows?
What a strange journey.
You forget, when "Easy Rider"
came out, he was on the cover
of the biggest magazine,
"Life" magazine.
And he was a bona fide icon.
And then what happens to this?
He's there for that moment.
He is the guy in 1969.
And then he goes to Peru, and
he shoots this really acid
cowboy movie.
And he sort of disappears.
And then we see him pop up in
"Apocalypse Now" in the
jungle, doing this crazy rant.
What a life.
And I just think the guy,
he never stopped.
And at the end of his life, he's
literally watching the
old cowboy movies.
It's just reconnecting
with that
original myth of his childhood.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that
his early success as a
director hemmed him in and made
him kind of afraid of
being able to get back
to where he was?
[INAUDIBLE]
TOM FOLSOM: His first movie,
just from a financial
standpoint, take $300,000, you
and your buddy, and you go to
New Orleans.
You start shooting
on Mardi Gras.
And then from these sort of
beginnings, trying to chase a
parade down, with these little
16 millimeter cameras, and
everybody's sort of an acid
and going nuts, and this,
that, the other.
That makes $40 million
at the box office.
So studios are, basically,
like, whoa.
I mean, he really does
revolutionize Hollywood.
It's sort of the idea that, if
this guy's not going to be
able to come through the front
door and be like a Paul
Newman, like a good boy actor,
and like the shining star,
he's going to change the system
so it works for him.
It was sort of a product
of his time.
I mean a movie like that
was bound to happen.
In some ways "Midnight
Cowboy" did that.
But it was really "Easy
Rider" that did that.
And so Hopper gets the chance
to do, basically, any movie
that he wants to do.
And he's really passionate,
though, about this sort of
trippy Western that he'd written
called "The Last
Movie." And they gave him
$1 million for it.
He had final cut.
It's a really personal vision,
but it's very strange.
I, personally, think it's super
groovy, but people at
the time, critics,
sort of hated it.
But it did win the Venice
Film Festival.
It's like one of these films,
that if you talk in film
circles, it's like this
great lost work.
Because it was edited so many
times, and no one knows what
exactly the definitive version
of "The Last Movie" is.
But he wanted it to be the
great American art film.
And he banked it all on that.
I mean all this creative capital
went into making "The
Last Movie." And it
was shelved by the
studios within a week.
Because he wouldn't recut
it to the way they
wanted to cut it.
So it's an experimental film.
But I think after that, Hopper
was lucky to have ever made
another film again.
But the films that he would make
after that were like--
he wanted narratives that
people could follow.
So I think he lost some of
that, we're going to make
something that's totally crazy,
totally nuts, for the
sake of, I can do a really
straight-up Hollywood movie.
And if you look at "Colors",
it's a Hollywood movie.
It's a buddy cop movie.
It's very mainstream.
It's just the subject matter
was just about three years
before its time.
I think he probably still really
harbored dreams of
making that sort of great
film, at the end.
And it just proved really
elusive to him.
AUDIENCE: How would you contrast
or compare that
personal vision of "The Last
Movie" with his connections
with pop art?
It seems like there's something
slightly disjointed
about this personal artist's
vision and the very
commercialized, generic?
TOM FOLSOM: Absolutely.
Hopper really believed that "The
Last Movie" was going to
change things.
This was a guy who thought that
"Easy Rider" was just a
warm-up for his grand plans.
I mean, who could blame
him for thinking
that at that time?
This was a guy who was so well
versed in what was happening
in art, and he wanted to
bring that sensibility.
He thought that people
were to going to
love "The Last Movie".
He thought it was going to
be another revolution.
But like he just found out
that people weren't
interested.
They wanted that easy ride of
"Easy Rider," this very
straight narrative.
That's sort of the one thing
that I didn't know about
Hopper when I came
to this book.
And that's the one thing that
became the centerpiece was
"The Last Movie." And to
me, I thought that
was his heroic gesture.
I mean this was a guy who
could've done anything.
And he banks it all on his
personal vision, in a really
hostile environment of the
corporate studios.
Just the fact that he was able
to do it, I think it's pretty
extraordinary.
But really, just the fact that
he stuck behind his vision.
And I think it's a vision that
you can't totally write off to
cocaine and drugs.
That was the movie he
wanted to make.
I mean just like "Easy
Rider" was a film.
It wouldn't have been the same
film without pot, so it's part
of the fabric of it.
And cocaine was in
"The Last Movie."
But it was his vision.
And so I thought was, again,
a pretty epic thing, a man
against the corporate
studio system.
And he took them on.
And he was totally fearless.
He paid for it.
AUDIENCE: I have one question.
TOM FOLSOM: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
Linda Manz.
What is she like?
What's her story, there?
TOM FOLSOM: Linda Manz
is just really cool.
I mean it's just, you
can imagine her--
a lot of people know her from
the film "Days of Heaven", the
Terrence Malick move.
She provides the voiceover
for that.
We all kind of grow older,
and maybe we lose
some of that intensity.
But you know, it's
still there.
You can't change who you are.
But it was pretty magical
getting to spend some time and
look through old photo albums,
Polaroids from "Days of
Heaven" and her showing
up to like her first--
not job interview--
acting gig in like
a Fonzie t-shirt
and smoking a cigarette.
That's how she would show
up for the audition.
It was amazing.
But yeah, just one of the
characters that you get to
meet in Hopper-land,
here, in the book.
Cool.
It's been a lot of fun.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.